اسلحة متطورة لحزب الله. وقال
تقرير عبري نشرته صحيفة اس
جنونه. موسكو تحذر ان ردة فعلها
ستكون غير متوقعة على انضمام
خلال اشهر وسنكسب الحرب قبل
نهاية العام. انقرة تعرض اجلاء
والتطورات. بريطانيا تتوقع قيام
موسكو بمحاولة ضم مناطق اوكرانية
في طلب انضمامها للحلف. الصين
تعتذر عن استضافة كأس اسيا الفين
الانضمام الى روسيا. صحف
اسرائيلية. موسكو سمحت بنقل
بمواصلة الضغط الاقتصادي على
روسيا. فنلندا تنتظر قرار الناتو
العبرية لو لم ترغب روسيا في نقل
اسلحتها الى حزب الله لما حدث
الجنود الاوكرانيين الجرحى من
ازوكستال. وزارة الدفاع الروسية
الناتو كدولة موالية لروسيا مثل
المجر في اوروبا. وهنا لن تسكت
تزال صعبة جدا. السلطات الموالية
لروسيا في خرسون تعلن نيتها
بالاضافة الى استهداف مستودعي
ذخيرة بصواريخ دقيقة. الاوضاع
فهل هي نهاية العلاقات الممتدة
منذ عقود ومجنون كوريا يواصل
واشنطن التي قالت التقارير انها
منزعجة جدا من موقف اردوجان بل
واضاف نتابع حاليا التطورات
المتعلقة بالسويد وفنلندا لكن
البيولوجية وتصفها الاستخبارات
الاوكرانية تقول روسيا ستهزم
وصولها الى لبنان. مشيرا الى ان
ما حدث هو احد التكتيكات
قوات نووية سنتخذ الاجراءات
اللازمة. مجموعة الدول السبع
يشغلون مناصب تنفيذية في شركات
روسية كبرى مثل غز بروما وهم
الانتقامية من اسرائيل. الرياض
وواشنطن وطريق جديد يمر بالاشواك
الرئيس الفنلندي انه اخبر بوتين
كيف ان التحركات الروسية الاخيرة
كييف. ويؤكد مشاركة اكثر الوسطاء
نفوذا في المفاوضات لكنها لا
ذلك. هذه اسلحة روسية متطورة
ووصلت الى الاراضي السورية قبل
زالنسكي يستقبل وفد الحزب
الجمهوري بالكونجرس الامريكي في
صعبة في دومبس والقوات الروسية
تحاول الاقل اظهار بعض النصر.
ليس لدينا رأي ايجابي بانهم
ارتكبوا خطأ في الناتو فيما
هيمنة روسيا على جزيرة سنيك يشل
ملاحتنا البحرية. واشنطن تتهم
يتعلق من قبل ضد تركيا هذا
الموقف قد يجعل تركيا تظهر داخل
وثلاثة وعشرين بسبب تداعيات
جائحة كورونا. الدفاع الاوكرانية
اثني عشر اسما جديدا منها طريقة
بوتين لودميلا وبعض اقاربه الذين
تعلن استهداف ثمان وعشرين نقطة
عسكرية حصينة في اوكرانيا
موسكو باستغلال مجلس الامن كمنبر
دولي وتندد باتهامات موسكو
من ان انضمام فنلندا الى حلف
الشمال الاطلسي الناتو والتخلي
ترد امريكا على تركيا ويبدأ
الانقسام في الناتو. الاحداث
يواجهون تجميدا للاصول وحظرا على
السفر. روسيا اذا نشر الناتو
خلال استفتاءات مزورة. وخلال ذلك
فرضت بريطانيا عقوبات جديدة طالت
انضمام فنلندا والسويد الى
الناتو مبررا للصحفيين انه لا
يمر دون رد. معارضة تركية.
الرئيس التركي اردوغان لا يريد
يريد ان يرى تكرار الخطأ نفسه
الذي ارتكب عندما انضمت اليونان
الخارجية الروسية اشارت الى انه
ستكون هناك اجراءات انتقامية.
بوتين تهديدا محددا بالانتقام من
الخطوة الفنلندية. لكن وزارة
وقالت موسكو ان انضمام اي من
السويد وفنلندا الى حلف ناتو لن
اتصال هاتفي انه لا يوجد اي
تهديد لامن فنلندا. بينما قال
الى جانب غزو اوكرانيا غيرت
البيئة الامنية لفنلندا ولم يوجه
حرب باردة. حذر الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين نظيره الفنلندي
من اعلان بيونج يانج تفشي فيروس
كورونا واعلان حالة الطوارئ
عن وضعها المحايد سيكون خطأ وقال
بوتين للرئيس ساولي مينيستو خلال
احدث خطوة بعد تنصيب يونسوكيول
رئيسا جديدا لكوريا الجنوبية.
روسيا وهم يدركون ضرورة
الاستقلالية عن الاسواق الغربية.
بكين ام ان العلاقات ستنكسر بين
الطرفين الى غير رجعة خصوصا بعد
الجرعات من لقاح لخوفها حرب
واشنطن البيولوجية عليها. وبعد
وطلب من الرياض عدم المضي قدما
في الصفقة. جاءت هذه الزيارة بعد
مشاهدة المملكة الامريكي الضعيف
مع حليفتها اوكرانيا. بلاد
عن الصين فقالت دوجن الصين حضرت
نفسها جيدا لمواجهة الغرب عكس
البلاد كوريا الشمالية تعلن عن
وفاة اكثر من عشرين شخصا من بين
لبوتين. روسيا هي مجموعة قيم
مقدسة كما هي مكة بالنسبة
او الى العدم. الامر خطير جدا.
فبوتين الى حد ما مثل صوفي غامض.
مسبوق بسبب تراجع الدعم العسكري
الامريكي للرياض بينما كانت
الولايات المتحدة بقلق متزايد
بسبب تنامي العلاقات السعودية
العملية فلن يكون هناك لاروسيا
ولا غرب ولا عالم عربي ولا شيء
تحذير المخابرات الوطنية
الامريكية من سعي روسيا والصين
كوريا الشمالية على اسلحتها هذا
العام. وجاء الاختبار بعد ساعات
حوالي مائة واربعة وسبعين الفا
من المصابين بتلك الحمى الغامضة،
البيولوجية حقا؟ في غضون ذلك
فالمجنون يؤكد جنون بلاده ويطلق
لتحقيق تقدم مع والامارات تتزامن
الخطوة مع توتر سعودي امريكي غير
وبعد ما ادى اليمين الدستوري دعا
يول نظيره كوريا الشمالية الى
كل تلك الاصابات في كوريا
الشمالية هل بدأت الحرب
واغلاق المدن وزيادة التدابير
الاحترازية. روسيا او الفناء.
انها ستنهار كبلد مستقل. فهذا
سيعني تباعا انهيار العالم. اما
يحمل ذات الافكار مع الرئيس
الروسي يقول اذا لم ننتصر في هذه
المجنون. وسط انتشار سريع للحمى
الغامضة وظهور فيروس كورونا في
دينية خيانتها ليست مجرد خيانة
بلد وانما خيانة الرب. بالنسبة
الكثير لا يفهمونه لكني افهمه.
فروسيا بالنسبة له تشبه رسالة
اخر وهذا يعني اننا ان هزمنا
سنأخذ العالم معنا الى المجهول
واسرائيل تعترض وبريطانيا تواصل
رشق روسيا بالاتهامات وتغدقها
للمسلمين. ولو كانت هناك فرضية
ان روسيا ستخسر الحرب ما يعني
والفيلسوف الروسي الكسندر دوجين
واقرب الاشخاص الى بوتين والذي
واشنطن قد اكدت مرارا التزامها
بامن المملكة اذ زودتها ببطاريات
باتريوت الدفاعية. فهل تنجح
واشنطن بثني الرياض عن خططها مع
نزع سلاحه النووي معتبرا صواريخ
بيونج يانج تهديدا للامن
ثلاثة صواريخ باليستية باتجاه
بحر اليابان عن اي جنون نتحدث في
العالمي. وتعد الصواريخ الاخيرة
الاختبار السادس عشر الذي تجريه
الصينية ما دفعها لارسال احد
مسؤوليها لمناقشة الامر مع
بينما ترفض بيونج يانج عروضا من
المجتمع الدولي لتزويدها بملايين
وبحث مع الامير الصغير عزم
السعودية على شراء اسلحة صينية.
الامير الصغير محمد بن سلمان.
وزار مدير المخابرات المركزية
الامريكية ويليام برينز العاصمة
الرياض سرا بحسب مجلة الامريكية.
بالعقوبات فهل ترد موسكو على
ذلك؟ ظهور الخلافات. تشعر
البيولوجية؟ والمجنون يواصل
تجربة الصواريخ للمرة السادسة
يعد ذلك تقربا من بوتين سلاح
روسي يصل لحزب الله في لبنان
تحالف طويل؟ كوريا الشمالية تعلن
عن هذه الفاجعة. فهل بدأت الحرب
المتحدة ايقافه اما ان تنتصر
روسيا او يزول العالم بالسلاح
ومن بعدها تاتي السويد اردوجان
يزعج امريكا برفضه لفنلندا فهل
الهدوء الذي يسبق العاصفة. فهل
تكون فنلندا الهدف القادم لموسكو
النووي. هكذا قالها اكثر الاشخاص
المقربين من بوتين بل هو توقع
للحرب العالمية الثالثة ام انه
تهديد عابر. روسيا وفنلندا.
عشرة خلال فترة الحرب الروسية
الاوكرانية. فهل تستطيع الولايات
التقرب الى الصين، فهل يحدث شرخ
في العلاقات بين الطرفين بعد
التوتر يزداد بين السعودية
وامريكا وواشنطن تحذر الرياض من
جيرانها للناتو. فهل هي الحرب
العالمية يا سادة?